some of the most common
underlying conditions slash
comorbidities for covid are things over
which individuals have some control
and um just you know this is this is
anecdotal anecdotal-ish um i
received the oregon health authority's
regular covet emails um
and i've been doing that i've been i've
been looking at them since the beginning
of the pandemic they come out many times
a week
and i've noted this and in fact here we
have zach you can show me this is just a
web version of the most recent one it
came out on
um yesterday um so they're talking about
safety and the very bottom
every every time one of these comes out
they talk about cases and deaths
and they always have a separate little
paragraph for each of the deaths
recorded since the last one has come
out and i have yet to see one and again
i've not seen absolutely every one of
these so it's possible i missed one
but every single death that i have seen
and there's been 2779 in
oregon thus far attributed to kovid
has as the final sentence either he had
underlying conditions
or she or presence of underlying
conditions is being confirmed
i have never seen a death reported in
the oregon health authority's
emails that they send out that there
were no underlying conditions and again
i may have missed one
but it is at least vanishingly rare and
so this
zach if i may um
raises the question of well okay what
are then the underlying conditions what
are the comorbidities which are often
used interchangeably these two terms
underlying conditions and comorbidities
for covid
what are they and um you know strangely
given the underlying conditions is this
term that is used in oregon health
authorities
emails every single time they don't have
it defined on their website anywhere
and i went down that stupid rabbit hole
a bit
looking for you know who defines it
which way um
and you know i ended up with the cdc um
for you know covert 19. here we go
people with certain medical conditions
which is the
then it's updated regularly and the
you know it's it's okay it's got a lot
of hedging and such
um and there's a lot of things that we
don't have control over things like
cancer and chronic kidney disease and
copd chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease and dementia
diabetes i will say that some of those
that we've looked at
already even though some diabetes some
copd some chronic kidney disease
while not dealable with particularly
effectively
in the moment once you already have it
had you had
access to excellent quality of life
resources early on
things like good diet and active
exercise and time outside and such
you would likely have at least delayed
these things um and you might not have
them
have them now so there is there is an
ability to um
make yourself healthier even against um
some of these things
um but less so once you already have
them and then actually zach if if i can
just have my screen back here
um there's a it's a fairly long list
but um the page also includes down near
the bottom
these three things overweight and
obesity overweight and obesity as
a category smoking current or former
and that's interesting you know we
talked early on like in april of last
year i think about there being some
counter-intuitive data
um about about smoking uh and
you know how protective it was or was
not actually against
covid but at this point they've got
smoking current or former and the list
of
uh comorbidities for covid and substance
use disorders
and all of those things individuals have
some control over
and yeah it's hard and yes sometimes
people really can't seem to
to to make it work and to extricate
themselves from the grip of whatever it
is
uh and um you know all of us struggle
with with
something probably in in some related
health space right where we know that we
aren't doing absolutely the most that we
could do to
make ourselves the most healthy and and
anti-fragile against things like
sarsko v2 but but we also
have what seems to be a downplaying of
those
those conditions over which people do
have control like
if every single death that i have seen
in the oregon health authority
attributed to kovid
also says that the person who died
either had underlying conditions or that
their underlying conditions were being
confirmed
and if separately i have seen and i
wasn't i didn't chase it down but
separately i've seen that the most
common underlying condition that people
have
is being overweight is being obese or
overweight
well that is something over which we
have control and
you know me saying that isn't fat
shaming it is talking about the actual
truth
that something about and it's going to
be in metabolic syndrome space right
that something about
being you know having a lot more weight
on your frame
than is optimal allows the virus to get
in and grab a hold more easily than it
otherwise
or it could be could be a third
correlate it could be that sedentary
lifestyles produce
weight gain and um result in you getting
less vitamin d
but somehow counteracting these things
and you know advice that we've been
giving
go outside right um yeah i mean going
outside doesn't inherently cause you to
lose weight but no but
my point is
not only have we seen um probably over
reporting
of cases from you know again following
from this new york times article from
last summer with
you know the high critical threshold
values uh for for the pcr test for
for kovid um but we're also seeing
uh like basically no discussion on the
media
about the things that each of us could
be doing
to help reduce the risk the only thing
we are being told the
only tool we are given is be vaccinated
that is the only thing we are allowed to
discuss
it's not just you can't talk about
ivermectin because that's medical
misinformation
you can't talk about losing weight is
that medical misinformation
like seriously this is it's it's
diabolical
it is diabolical the fact is this is a
complex system it has lots of different
inputs being vaccinated does make you
much less likely to get the disease it's
one factor in the equation and guess
what
being an appropriate weight for your
size seems to be
strongly correlated with not dying from
covid
yep it's a comorbidity of covid that's
what it means
why don't we talk about this yeah no the
problem is there's some sort
the most generous thing you could say is
that there is some sort of
a political map that makes certain
factors in your likelihood of
contracting the disease
um discouraged from discussion and other
factors
highlighted beyond all proportion and
the elephant in the room being
that actually there is uh an alternative
that seems to be highly effective
which we're not allowed to discuss
because um uh the cdc
and its bizarre set of beliefs suggested
it would be counterproductive
well it just it further infantilizes all
of us it takes away our agency the idea
that none of us can do anything all you
know just
at first and you know we were we were in
favor we hated it but we were in favor
of strong lockdowns to shut this thing
down and
you know instead we've got like a year
and a half of garbage right
um but you know we were in favor of some
of the
things that could have been done and
where as far as i can tell
done kind of nowhere effectively with
the possible exception of
gosh taiwan maybe south korea like a
vietnam like early on some of the
countries that actually like really
locked down and really had low case
loads
i'm not sure i'm remembering exactly
which countries did it but
um but actually there are things that
individuals can do
an individual level and population level
analyses are different
but in the case of actually you're
reducing the risk
that you will get sick and put further
strain on the system and
and and make other people sick that's
win-win that's good for the individual
and good for the group and yet somehow
those things that individuals can
do are completely taken off the table
with the exception of the one thing that
you can go and you can get your shot
and you still have no agency in that
like
it's it's it's it all seems in service
of
you do what we say and we'll keep you
safe
and you know what they're doing a
terrible job of keeping us safe
so why why do we believe them now yeah
i think that i think this is this is
worth pointing out they have done a
terrible job of keeping us safe they've
told us that masks didn't work when they
believed that they did
um they told us they prevented us from
going onto beaches and in parks right
they kept us
indoors for a virus that transmits
indoors
pretty much exclusively right and the
fact is just simply spending more time
outdoors would have reduced the rate of
transmission for everyone right even if
all of us even if the entire planet went
outdoors at the same time right in fact
we've
just written this in the afterword of
the book right in addition
in addition going outdoors especially
the beach would have produced an awful
lot of vitamin d which seems to be
a a critical contributor to a native
uh innate immunity to this disease and
mental health we could have seen each
other
unmasked outside my god so you know
let's put it this way
we know from the question of masks from
the question of
outdoor transmission from the question
of vitamin d
that they have given us bad information
or failed to give us good information
when the evidence was very clear about
it and that has had a huge cost in terms
of uh suffering damage to people and the
loss of life
so who the hell are these people to be
declaring what's misinformation
yeah right they've been purveyors of
misinformation and the best thing we can
say
is that maybe they thought it was good
information
at the time but they're hardly the
[Music]
oracle
you